welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Bost and Deadpool 3 will almost
certainly include Patrick Stewart
Charles Xavier according to an interview
with Patrick Stewart by the always
inquisitive Josh Horowitz on his happy
side confused podcast but what will that
Cameo look like and what reason do we
have for this role to be more involved
than his well in his words disappointing
Cameo and Doctor Strange to the
Multiverse of Madness in this video I'm
going to break down how it's not the
X-Men movies that will be the most
Center in Deadpool 3's crosshairs but
rather Marvel's own Multiverse Saga
prologue and multi ierse of Madness as
this film seeks to saiz and crystallize
any of the perceived stumbles as Marvel
Studios has rolled out its latest phase
now it seems like Deadpool 3 will be the
biggest movie of 2024 and to catch you
up on this X-Men history starting this
Monday January 8th new rockstars will be
releasing weekly in-depth breakdowns of
the fox X-Men films all 13 of these
films from 2000 to 2020 in our X-Men
Snick Snick rewatch Series so on Monday
I will be revisiting the very first X
X-Men film to break down new details
that have only now emerged and what
exactly from this film Kevin feige wants
to bring back in the MCU in this
upcoming mutant homecoming okay
Professor X let's talk about him late
last year I broke down the 23 cameos
that have either been confirmed or
speculated to appear in Deadpool 3 and
Patrick Stewart was definitely on that
list because late last year on February
9th 2023 Patrick Stewart told
comicbook.com about Deadpool 3 I've been
told to stand by I know nothing more
than that honest and then this week the
great Josh Horowitz interviewed Patrick
Stewart for the happy sad confused show
and asked him about playing Charles
Xavier I also of course want to mention
um your wonderful tenure in the X-Men
franchise eight appearances I believe as
Professor X Charles Xavier Patrick do
you know how many times you died in the
X-Men series of those eight appearances
do you know how many times Charles
died no four that is a horrible ratio
you died 50% of the movies you appeared
I don't know what that what does that
say Patrick I don't
know I don't know um but I do now have
every confidence that he's still
around on the X-Men front I would be
shocked if your buddy Hugh Jackman who
is returning in Deadpool 3 one of his
first phone calls was not to you Patrick
I'm gonna guess I might see Patrick
Stewart in in a Deadpool Wolverine
movie it it has come up um there's been
a process but you know the last two
three years have been so difficult with
yeah both the the labor problems and the
health problems so Josh was referring to
the fact that Charles Xavier died in
2006 as X-Men the Last Stand obliterated
by Phoenix Gene gray in 2017's Logan
stabbed in bed by Wolverine's clone x24
and in 2022 Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness his face was split
in half by Scarlet Witch W maxoff and I
say face split in half not next snapped
because if you look closely she grabs
two parts of his face and like rip him
apart now I was trying to figure out
what fourth instance Josh was referring
to and I think he was talking about
2014's xend Days of Future Past which
doesn't show Charles's death per se but
it was implied that those Sentinels
might have killed all of them in various
past instances before Kitty Pride was
able to reset the timeline and prevent
that fate and in the final part of the
movie we do see the Sentinels get close
to Charles and kitty and Logan as
they're waiting for history to change in
1973 to rewrite that future and while
those blasts from the Sentinels fire at
Charles and he covers his face he
vanishes along with everything else from
this timeline at the last second so I
wouldn't say he technically dies there
but I guess you could count that as like
a moment of death but Patrick Stewart
was referring to the difficulties with
Film Production during covid and the
complete halt on production during the
labor strikes by the wga and sag after
strikes throughout the year of 2023 and
specifically Deadpool 3 was rushing
production in June and July of last year
to get ahead of the SAG after strike and
that Rush might have resulted in the
lack of onset security that allowed so
many set photos and videos to leak but
but the decision by Ryan Reynolds and
director Sean Levy to shoot as much as
they could practically in an open air
set with physical set pieces is really a
key component for why Deadpool 3 could
be such a refreshing change of pace from
the rest of Marvel's Multiverse Saga and
could be the story that actually fixes
it which would explain why Marvel
Studios is putting all of its chips on
this one Marvel movie in 2024 due to
security concerns and for secrecy and
for health and safety so much of the
Marvel properties of the past few years
have been shot on green screens or the
volume or other digitally composited
sets and viewers have just started to
sense that this doesn't feel authentic
the actors are often not in the same
room or not knowing who they're in the
scene with or just not knowing what
movie they're shooting a scene for gwith
paltro said that she forgot that she was
in Spider-Man homecoming Bri Larson said
that the first thing she shot for Marvel
Studios was the post credit scene for
Captain Marvel in which Carol Danvers
returns to earth and Avengers compound
after the snap and asks where his Fury
but lson said that they put her on a
green screen set and would not tell her
who was in the scene with her or what
movie this was for who else is in the
room and like five people and I was like
okay and I went you know where's Fury
and then just kind
of Elizabeth Olsson told vanady fair in
that amazing lie detector test video
that she never even met John krinski and
this was after Multiverse of Madness
showed Wanda maximoff killing krin's
version of Reed Richards in that
Illuminati Massacre is the smartest man
alive
no I don't know him though um but I
would never assume that an actor would
be the smartest man
alive you don't know him at all I don't
think so no I've never met him you were
in the same movie I've never met him
she's coming out truthful never met him
and he's already told me that I've lied
a couple times I've never met that man
I've met his
wife okay then by the way it's tough
when you're reading news to have a sense
of the full context of what you're
reading like is it biased is it credible
are the sources more substantial than
user 25289 to9 atx.com well grounded
news gives you all of that context and
so much more ground news is an app and a
website that provides you with articles
from around the world in one place and
additional contexts that other media
sources often don't show you in order to
help avoid disinformation and just be
better informed ground news gives you
details on the coverage you're reading
like the total articles published on a
story their political affiliation who
owns each Source making it easy to see
how affiliation and vested interest can
shape the narrative and how that
affiliation might skew the coverage of
that story scrolling down I can see
every headline on the story ranging from
left Center and right leading outlets
and you can do this for various topics
like Marvel or HBO or even the 20204 US
election what Brown news is doing is
super important and it's part of why we
are thrilled to have them sponsoring
this video and why it's such a good tool
to have access to in the leadup to the
election or even when Major Movie Studio
news drops to check it out for yourself
go to ground. news/ rockstars you can
subscribe using the link in the
description for less than $1 per month
or get 30% off Unlimited access to the
Vantage subscription which is what I use
again that's ground. news/ rockstars
supporting our sponsors also supports
his channel so thank you to ground news
and Josh orwood similarly interviewed
Daniel Craig and asked him about the
reports that he had shot a scene as
Baler the brave in this whole Illuminati
sequence because we saw stunt previous
footage that showed Baler the brave dead
and we saw Daniel Craig's face clearly
in concept art for Baler the brave but
apparently this was removed from the
film have you ever heard of the
character balder the
brave no there was aort Daniel that you
were going to be in Doctor Strange don't
wasn't
it don't you hide behind that mug
[Laughter]
Daniel I don't know what you're talking
about so naturally Josh asked Patrick
Stewart what it was like to shoot that
sequence in Multiverse of Madness
there's nothing sentimental about the
way they dispatched you in the doctor
strange movie do you I've talked to a
lot of the actors that were doing the
Multiverse of Madness this movie that
that was a very interesting production
I'm just curious like do were you alone
like were you with the other actors do
you remember like the circumstances of
that I was alone you were alone that's
what I thought the magic of movie making
I think I think the the big scene um I
think each one of the leading actors had
the same experience they were shot on
their own yeah that's that's what I've
heard frustrating and disappointing by
the way you have to watch Josh's entire
interview with Patrick Stewart in the
link in the description it's such an
amazing conversation so the difference
with Deadpool 3 is that they are clearly
shooting this film in a different way to
contrast the experience of shooting
movies like Multiverse of Madness this
time they're doing it in open air with
practical sets security be damned we've
seen some of this in set photos some of
which we can show some of which we can't
but spoiler warning skip to this time if
you don't want to know what these are
we've definitely seen imagery of
Deadpool in Wolverine fighting on the
ruins of the 20th century box logo
decapitating Sabertooth an appearance
from modded versions of red skull's car
the Fantastic Four car Moon Knight's
cupcake truck like unless production
spent thousands of dollars building
decoy versions of these vehicles props
and sets just to throw off fans this
would be when they have super limited
time to shoot this movie around the
strikes it just seems like this is all
real and they are building these
physical sets because that is the field
that those OT movies had they wanted to
feel like a sort of campy throwback they
want the reaction to all those things to
be on the actor's faes and yeah it just
seems like this going to be a big meta
Battle Royale where Deadpool kills the
X-Men universe or where Deadpool
desperately tries to save the X-Men
Universe whatever happens at Deadpool 3
the post-credit scene of the Marvels
confirmed that a version of Charles
Xavier is waiting in the wings of the
MCU and that's got to be Patrick Stewart
right like remember that alternate
universe that Monica Rambo ends that
movie in Hank McCoy tells binary Maria
Rambo that Charles is waiting for an
update so by Patrick St telling us it
has come up there has been a process
yeah he's just confirming what we
already know he's going to be in
Deadpool 3 but specifically if you
listen closely it sounds like this is an
appearance he has not shot yet there
have been some unconfirmed rumors that
the villain character that Emma Corin is
playing is Cassandra Nova Charles
Xavier's evil twin from the womb who
tried to strangle him but like baby
Charles defeated her with a psychic
blast but she survived and she came back
to get him later on in life I doubt that
Deadpool 3 would kill off Charles Xavier
yet again especially since Patrick
Stewart considered his experience on
Multiverse of Madness to be quote
frustrating and disappointing so to have
Charles get killed Again by like a long
lost evil twin sister or by Deadpool
goofing around I think that would just
feel like something we've seen before
that's why I think the blood bath in
Deadpool 3 is going to be presented as a
kind of parody of the massacre in
Multiverse of Madness something that is
so bloody and could only have happened
if all these actors were actually in the
same place at the same time and in this
instance I think Wade Wilson is actually
going to try to prevent these killings
to do everything in his power to protect
Charles Xavier even to the point of
losing his own Limbs and spraying
Professor X and his blood like maybe
unwillingly at first because we need
Wade to answer for all the times he has
dissed Patrick Stewart version of
Professor X in the past Deadpool films
let us go talk to the professor makavo
Stewart these timelines are so confusing
the day I decide to become a crime
fighting swizzler who rooms with a
bunch of other little whiners at the
neverland Mansion of some creepy old
bald Heaven's Gate looking mother on
that day I'll send your Shiny Happy ass
a friend request to me Charles Xavier
being immune to Wade's snark and
telepathically chatting with Wade inside
his mind while he's using Wade's body as
a human shield would just be the best
way to redeem all the times these films
have made the character die I'm so
excited for you to join us for our
upcoming X-Men stick stick rewatch
series the first video is coming on
Monday the best way to support new rock
stars and everything we're doing is to
grab some merch over at nerd ride. shop
you can follow me on all social
platforms at e AOS subscribe to all
three channels in the new rockstars
Network thanks for watching and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
bye
n